hey we partnered up with a company
called dreamworld to bring you exclusive
anime merch that you can't find anywhere
else if you love demon Sayer we've got
conjured off my boy sided sue and so
much more check it out at enter
dreamworld calm or click the link in the
description
what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I have quite the video
for you today this is a huge chapter in
demons there and we got so much to talk
about so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you enjoy these Demon Slayer
videos I want to keep them coming the
best thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video we cover a
lot of anime on the channel and it's
always fun to see what the fan bases
favorite anime is in one way we can
judge that is by the number of likes so
if demons there is one of your favorites
be sure to absolutely destroy that like
button let's see if we can get something
epic like over 25,000 likes if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification Bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer reviews
remember that you can get early access
to these Demon Slayer reviews by
following anime out for audio on Spotify
and Apple podcast or wherever else you
listen to podcasts check out the links
in the description in a previous video I
told you guys that we were the number
one trending anime podcast in Great
Britain and we just had the rest of the
world left to conquer and after that at
one point we were the number one
trending anime podcast in the world and
that blew me away so big thank you for
that keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video I will be talking
about the latest chapter chapter 203
after all you've been warned
now without further ado let's jump into
it if you'll remember in the last
chapter demon Tundra hurt Connell who
had succeeded in injecting him with the
human medicine we didn't know the space
she was in and we didn't know what would
happen to touch it off but we did know
that for the first time we saw a face
full of regret on demon tundra space now
we start with an image of Medical crying
she continues to beg Tundra to go home
she wants them to go home together this
chapter is called the end of the thread
perhaps pointing to a thread linking
them and especially time zero to moves
on we see tundra and his left eye is
crying while the right side of his face
still looks like it did before with
infection these scenes are more
metaphoric than anything and they showed
that the real tundra is still trapped
inside
while Mouzon sells through the event
Angela are in control outside real times
are trapped in moves on like flesh wants
to go home with mezack oh but he says
he's really tired he begs God to let him
go home he reaches out for new Zucco
determined to go back and then moves on
cells try to place doubt in tundra Joe's
mind in a way through his cells moves on
still lives in demon Tiger oh and he
hasn't given up yet moves on tells
Tundra that there's nothing to go back
to time Joe's family is dead after all
however Tundra presents a different
viewpoint rather than the pessimistic
one moves on is trying to make him adopt
Tundra says that he still has memories
of those happy days and his bond with
Mexico won't disappear so he wants to go
back to be with no Zuko and to take
comfort in those happy memories moves on
tries to trick Tundra again he tells him
that Mexico is dead if you guys read the
seven deadly sins another series with
the demon king then you'd recognize the
similarities here Mele Otis also had to
fight an internal battle with the
previous demon king and the previous
demon king kept trying to trick him and
fill him with doubt the similarities are
striking especially with this chapter
Tundra does not fall for the lie though
and says that Mitsuko is alive and calls
moves on and his doubts a liar moves on
here is really representative of
something all of us have we all have
those doubts in our heads that try to
force us to adopt the pessimistic or
defeatist point of view however we don't
have to listen to that voice and those
doubts that tell us we're not good
enough for that we're failures or that
there's no point like Tundra we can
recognize that that voice is a liar we
get to choose whether we adopt the
pessimistic beliefs of our inner Musa or
whether we reject them we see tons rose
family members that have passed on
helping to push him up the connections
he's formed are helping him combat his
moves on doubts showing the importance
of human connections in life even when
people die the connections remain and
those memories can give us motivation
and help us move forward even during the
darkest times Mouzon tries to dismiss
the connections by calling them ghosts
and calling their efforts pointless Musa
tries to get Tundra to give up the will
to resist in any way he can he tries to
get hundra to take the blame for hurting
his comrades moves on tells Tundra that
he's responsible for spilling their
blood and that no one wants him to come
back to
real world however Concha won't give up
on getting back to the real world he
knows that as a demon he probably did
hurt them but he wants to go back anyway
and apologize moves on tells him they
won't forgive him even if he apologizes
and that's where we get an awesome line
from Tangier oh he says and I quote
that's not for me to decide and quote if
you have been around for long enough you
know I love philosophy and stoic
philosophy in particular which has a lot
of similarities to Buddhism which has
deeply influenced demon slayer within
stoicism the top good is virtue which
means doing the right thing no matter
what even if it means that the demon
Slayers are all stoic in that sense
because they are regularly willing to
risk their lives in order to do the
right thing which in this case is
helping the world by ridding it of
Mouzon and all of the suffering he's
causing one of the most important
principles in stoicism is that we must
always focus on what is inner control
rather than on what is not in our
control here Mulan is trying to
manipulate time zero by suggesting that
the opinions of others something Tundra
can't control should determine his
behavior he shouldn't apologize because
they won't forgive him but time zero
rejects this line of reasoning it
doesn't matter if they forgive him or
not what's in his control is doing the
right thing and the right thing in this
case is apologizing to them similarly it
is always within our power to do the
right thing and within stoicism that's
all you need to be happy tranquil and
free which is pretty much the opposite
of Mouzon who represents how fear and
vice can turn a human into a miserable
monster keep in mind then Goku died with
a smile on his face while moves on lid
for a millennium and never found
happiness when it comes to life for the
Stoics quality is much more important
than quantity Tundra is such a great
role model because he doesn't let his
fear and the temptation of living
forever influence his actions Mouzon
wants him to inherit his will but Tundra
just wants to go back to his friends
moves on doesn't give up though he tries
to make time zero feel guilty again by
asking is it okay that he shamelessly go
back to normal while so many others died
Musleh wants to use the emotion of shame
to get tundra to give up on going back
to the real world
that's when the medicine really seems to
be taking effect and tundra smells
wisteria a smell he associates with
Shinobu which makes sense
she did help Tamayo to create the
medicine just like in seven deadly sins
the medicine allows tangelos loved ones
to enter into his internal world and
help pull him out of his Mouzon induced
funk Mouzon is desperately trying to
hold on to Tangier oh he tries to speak
to his pride calling him a superior
creature think about it moves on is
pretty much offering tundra ultimate
power immortality and everything else
that could please the ego but tundra is
strong-willed enough with the help of
his friends to ignore all these
temptations there are more important
things like being true to your
principles and being there for other
people
Poussin keeps trying to get tundra in a
competitive selfish frame with other
humans
he tells ton show that the people who
died are wondering why they lost
everything in tundra didn't however
Tundra rejects this frame knowing that
people aren't as selfish as moves on
suggests as tundra points out they were
all selfless and as a result risked
their lives for others because they are
people who don't want others to go
through the same suffering and sadness
that they did in fact the ultimate thing
that would upset them is if tundra gave
up the will to return to the real world
after they did so much to help him
including saving his life on multiple
occasions if you think about it
logically you know that what Mulan is
saying is BS why would then Goku want
tundra dead when he sacrificed himself
so that Tundra could survive however in
our darkest moments we don't always
think logically and that's when it's
most important that like tangelo we
stick to our moral compass and choose
love over fear Musa tells Tundra that he
was chosen by God to be the perfect
creature and begs him but Angelo's
friends their love for him and his love
for them helped pull him through and
Mulan is left alone and his ultimate
fear seems like it's going to be
realized the ultimate eradication of his
existence the end of his thread you
can't help but notice how lonely his
path and end is he's left naked and
alone in a dark world while Tundras path
has led him to this place where he's
surrounded by countless people who love
him and are beyond glad to have him back
the contrast between the lonely Muslim
panel and the awakened congedo
surrounded by friends panel is great and
no doubt purposeful he awakens to Mexico
crying every
one gets excited and teary-eyed inosuke
says he's cool with the injury's tundra
gave him but Danny too hilariously says
he'll make tundra regret hurting his
wife we get a cute moment when a Zuko
looks nervous and she's like wife you
have to respect Sonny two's humor and
confidence he just never gives up in
keeps putting himself out there GU is
alive too and he gets to witness Tundra
and let's go crying and smiling together
probably one of the most touching panels
in the entire series especially after
all that these two have been through
they're finally both human and together
and Mulan seems to be gone for good
thankfully as I assumed Cano is still
alive Tundra ain't gonna look at each
other and smile another touching moment
especially because he must gain with his
boar mask is crying over tan judo it
also looks like Cano still has vision in
one eye remaining in my view times ER
and Cano better end up together
especially after we saw Mitsui an eager
Oh on the other side in Tundras vision
even though we never saw them crossing
over and they kind of seemed fine when
they were talking last time not only
should the survivors not feel guilty for
surviving they should live life to the
fullest now in order to honor those that
sacrifice their lives so that they could
still be here demon you Shira who's
grown on me over the years Christ
- out of happiness the demon cat is a-ok
I'm glad to inform you you should Oh
kisses Tommy Oh spin and cries it's over
we're told and chapter 203 is translated
here as the end we are told that the
long battle has come to an end and yet
the next issue is called the climax
which is usually the pinnacle of action
and we're left to wonder if this is the
end of demon slayer if this was the last
fight it's called here the long battle
but not the final battle so we'll have
to wait and see moves on and Tommy Oh
should be gone now but you should are
still alive suggesting that the demons
that we're already alive are still
running wild across the world but let me
know what you think is gonna happen next
is the climax just gonna be a nice wrap
up of Zetas - and mezu go getting
married or are we gonna actually get a
new conflict pop up in my view we
definitely do deserve some winding down
time where everyone can enjoy the
victory at least for a bit to be honest
I am a bit surprised that theme and
tundra went back to normal so soon and
we didn't see some crazy demon son Bree
but hey we did get some truly touching
moments and some great philosophy even
if it did feel a bit rush after so much
demon king height the manga is even
talking about the end now so we are
going to find out sooner or later what
the future for this popular manga we
love is gonna be I don't want to say
goodbye to these characters yet but from
the starts to now this has been an
awesome manga and I'm deeply grateful
that I've gotten to enjoy it with you
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
these Demon Slayer videos and want to
keep them coming no matter what the best
thing you can do is smash that like
button and share this video and if demon
stairs one of your favorite anime that
we cover make sure to really destroy
that like button to let the world know
your undying love for demon slayer in my
last demon center video we got 23,000
likes so let's see if we can get
something epic like 25,000 likes this
time if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial ring that
notification bell or you will miss
future to even say your videos and leave
suggestions for what demon slayer videos
you would like to see next in the
comments
lastly the YouTube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime uproar patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who helped us survive these
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank the legends
acknowledged by Lord we go himself baby
ray and Efrain a and the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Steven and Radha a Lola nitendo world
stealers the school bus Tyson Kirino
acquire respect but they have a Jonathan
King the CD and Brandon of aisles and
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings I'll just Anatoly kazansky
angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor
cricket XP Ted no Ted Joel Turk Joel
Stanton very gucci alicia actor animal
69 jessica calif on he no kami and water
Bonnie parks is Odie are 12 wrath to
Endora emperor otaku JCCC waka
the coach and according to Google
Translate the Chinese characters for
Emperor thank you all so much and I love
to see how global this community has
become if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon calm
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talked about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon calm and
Mail for link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the YouTube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us you can get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]